-My first guest is an Emmy- and
Golden Globe-nominated actress
who produces the new show
"Cruel Summer,"
which airs Tuesdays
at 10:00 p.m. on Freeform
and on Hulu the next day.
Please welcome Jessica Biel.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ah, I've been
looking forward to this.
Yes! Jessica!
-Jimmy!
-Jess, I've been
looking forward to this.
I cannot wait
to talk about this project.
You look fantastic.
It's great to see you.
How are you?
How's the fam?
How are the boys?
-Oh, they're good.
The family is big.
They're getting big so fast.
It's so weird.
They're so cute.
They're really cute.
They're stinking cute.
-The last time you FaceTimed me
after you had the baby,
immediately after
you had the baby,
and he started
doing a bit for me.
He was doing comedy.
-He did.
It was amazing.
He was in that little --
I don't know,
those weird plastic cribs
that they have
in the hospital rooms.
And he's laying right next to me
in the bed.
-He's so cute.
-But he was asleep,
and he just rolled over
and he just pressed his nose
up against the glass like this.
-I was like, "Dude,
that's a classic bit."
He's doing the classic bit.
I loved it.
Is Silas --
Are they loving each other?
Are they besties?
-I think they are.
-Yeah.
-I really do.
And I really was worried.
You know, you just never know
what's going to happen
and how your older one is gonna
feel about the little one.
And, man, they just think
each other are so funny.
And it's so amazing to watch.
It's so cute.
-Do they, like,
kind of freak out
because their dad
is in "Trolls,"
their mom was in "Pete the Cat"?
They hear these voices
and they go, like,
"Wait, what's going on?"
Do they understand
what you guys do?
-Well, Silas does.
Definitely with Justin
because of Branch.
That for sure
and also his music.
Whenever he hears Daddy's song,
he'll go,
"Oh, yeah, that's Dad,
that's Dad."
Like, "No big deal.
Yeah, whatever."
But the funny thing
about "Pete the Cat"
is I tried to get him
to watch the show.
He will not watch the show.
And yet he says,
"Hey, Mom, hey, Mom,
do one of those voices
from the show."
And I'm like,
"You've never seen the show.
You don't even know --"
He's just like, "Just do it,
Mom, just do it, Mom."
And so I'll, like,
do one of the voices.
"Okay, cool, Mom, cool."
-[ Laughs ]
Look, we've known each other
for a long time,
and I just was wondering if
I could just bring up a subject
and you could tell everyone
these stories that I've known,
if you don't mind
telling a couple stories.
-Yes, yes, let's do it.
-Do you remember
selling spa water?
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yes, I do.
-You scammed the neighborhood.
-Yeah, we scammed
the neighborhood.
My brother and I in Colorado,
when we were, I don't know,
9 and 6 or 8 and 5,
something like that.
We were in the tub
taking a bath,
and we just dumped
everything we had --
shampoo, conditioner, body wash,
bath bomb, salt, foamy whatever.
We probably peed in there,
I'm sure.
And then we just -- we poured it
all into plastic bottles
and we called it spa water
and we sold it
around the cul-de-sac.
[ Laughter ]
-And what were people
supposed to do
with spa water
once they received it?
-See, now, that's the thing.
Were you supposed to drink it
like a cucumber water
from the spa,
or were you supposed to do,
like, a refreshing spritz?
I think we were going
for a spritz
and not an actual ingestion,
but I don't really know.
-A spritz. You were not going
for a spritz at 6 years old.
Please.
Give me a break.
Can you also tell the story
about when you
first became famous
and someone came up to you
for the first time
and asked you
for your autograph?
I love this.
-Oh, yeah.
I was so embarrassed, Jimmy.
I didn't even know what to do.
This cute little girl came up,
and she said,
"I love you in "7th Heaven.
I love the show.
I'm a big fan.
Can I have your autograph?"
And I was like,
"Only if I can have yours."
She was like..."Okay."
-I love that you got
her autograph, as well.
I love that.
That's my favorite.
I want to talk to you
about "Cruel Summer."
I don't want to know
any spoilers,
but I'm loving the show.
-Okay.
-Everyone's talking about it.
So, can we explain
what this is about?
Or do you want me to explain it?
-Yes, a young girl goes missing
in this small Texas community,
and one of the other students
in the school
gets wrapped up
in this whole thing,
and it changes these
young women's lives forever.
And it ricochets through
the entire community.
-It is so good.
Every single episode is like
another going like,
"Wait, what?"
So this girl goes missing.
This other girl kind of takes
her place kind of in high school
and starts dating her boyfriend.
Then the girl's maybe
or maybe not missing,
and maybe she goes, "You know,
you were there, maybe?"
And she goes,
"You know something,
and you didn't say anything
about when I went missing."
-Right, and the whole show
is like dual perspective.
Who do you believe?
Who's telling the truth?
Who's lying?
-Yes. No, we don't know.
-I mean, my perception is mine,
and your reality is yours.
And the truth lies somewhere
in the middle, probably.
-You have a good eye
for shows like this.
How do you do it?
Do you just read these scripts
and you go,
"Oh, this is the one"?
-I think I just look
for something
that I am curious
about the mystery,
I don't know the answers,
where I'm like, "Ooh, I don't
know where this is going to go."
-Yeah.
-And I want to be in the show.
If I want to be in the show even
if I'm too old for the show,
like this one, then I feel like
it's probably a good one.
-Yeah, it's a great one.